can talk about the process of adapting a
novel into a screenplay the actual
physical process like how you begin it
you sit at your computer and where do
you write well that's never changed the
same thing that happened with Carroll
has happened with all subsequent
projects I read the novel obsessively
maybe four or five six times just
quickly make a bunch of notes that I
then never ever refer to ever again I
just write things down it's a bit like
rote memorization maybe that you you you
take this stuff in maybe by osmosis and
then I go away and I do something else
so I'll go to a bunch of baseball games
our own you know watch TV or all I'll do
go to Vegas something for a few weeks
and then I come back and if I've got say
ten weeks to do something I'll use eight
of them in other ways I won't even think
about it and then I'll sit down and I'll
write from page one to the end very
quickly and without stopping without
revising and without shuffling scenes
around there's something about a
structure for me arriving at how
something begins and ends provides a
structural tool and that's really the
way music mostly is composed so I look
at it that way and then the revision is
always the same if something is wrong on
page 46 you know the previous 45 pages
also have to be adjusted and all the
pages that follow because one thing is
off it sets something off in another
section I've never been someone who's
learned how to do that thing that I
always see with famous screenwriters you
know the cards the the ability to take
one scene here and put it here and this
it always seems
that's not my process it's got to all
work as a piece in one long act almost
you